Welcome back to human emotion.
Um,
in this course we've sort of
thought about what an emotion is,
sort of what are tools we can use to
trigger it and how we can measure it's
varying representations in our own face,
our laughter,
our bodily signals and most
recently even our brain.
Yet the most striking feature
about emotion is that it's
usually not experience
in isolation.
In fact,
we experienced it around other people
and it's what binds us to other people.
And in fact emotions are actually
thought of as the social glue of society.
Um,
so given that emotions
are rarely experienced in
isolation and that we have them
to connect us and bind us together,
we need to better understand this
social world of emotions we live in.
This can include experiencing emotions
with intimate partners and sort of one on
one or dyadic exchanges as
well as experiencing them
as part of a larger group
of people such as when
we cooperate or compete.
And so as we think about emotions
and how important they are to our own
individual life,
we want to remember how critical
they are to our social life.
And how they're literally the glue that
keeps us together as social creatures.
And so with this thought that we
live in this inherently social world,
um, how much do we know about
emotions in our social world?
How do emotions look in these lives,
social exchanges,
how do they underlie our most important
relationships and interactions like
romantic relationships, cooperating
with other people, working in teams.
These are some of the questions that
we'll begin to examine today in our first
part, um, of the emotions
and social world series. Um,
and in particular,
um,
what I'd like to start out as we think
about emotions in a social world is to
ask you to engage in a thought exercise.
So what I want you to do is after I
explained this to you, to pause the video,
take out a piece of paper and
write down this little exercise.
And when you're done, you can
click, play and resume the video.
So what I want you to do is think about
a recent time where you experienced a
very intense emotion. It could be
positive or it could be negative.
And what I want you to do is just to write
about first describing an emotion and
all the ways and tools that
we've talked about so far.
Sort of what did it look like, you
know, and your facial expressions.
What did you feel
physiologically in your body? Um,
what kind of subjective experience did
you have go through all the different
multiple channels of emotion responding
we've talked about and when you're done
with that,
think about for a second,
what was the social context
this emotion was embedded in?
Were there any other people?
The emotion was about,
were you around other people when the
emotion happened and was the emotion
something that really tied you to have
a relationship with another person?
And I'm curious to see if you find
that most of the intense emotions we
experience in everyday settings are
rarely about things that have only to do
with us.
And more often than not,
they are often truly about other people.
And they're the things
that really get us going.
The things that make us feel joyous
things is that make us feel angry and sad
are the emotions we have
around others or about others.
So take a moment to try to do this.
And when you're done,
we'll come back and talk a bit about
this introduction to emotions in a social
world.
So here we go.
We're going to start in our introduction
of emotions and a social world.
And I think of it as a question
of will I feel you feel we feel.
And in a sense,
what I want you to think about is the
fact that any one of us feels emotions,
but we're often thinking
about the emotions of other
people and the emotions of
all of us together as a collective group.
And so what we're going to do,
and sort of thinking about
this introduction to social
emotions is go through
the following roadmap.
We're going to start with an introduction
to what social emotions are in the
first place, followed by an
account that's been provided,
have a social function of emotion
across different levels of analysis.
Conclude a takeaway questions and
our expert interview for today.
So I'm going to start here with an
introduction to sort of what our social
emotions in the first place. What do we
mean when we think about this? So again,
this is our graph here,
thinking about this idea of emotions and
a social world and asking the question
of why are our emotions so social.
So you may remember earlier on in our
course we talked about the evolution of
emotion and here we discussed the early
ancestral origins of human man and how
he evolved into the current
form of human species.
We know today and in particular we talked
about the early environment that man
is thought to have evolved in called the,
you might remember the acronym,
the EEA or the uh,
environment of evolutionary adaptiveness.
And I would just want to do a quick
refresh because some of its central
properties I think are really critical
to answering this question of, well,
why are our emotions so
social in the first place?
So when we talked about,
for example, the EEA, right,
we went through the
different properties of it.
And let me just go through some of these
properties that appear to have given
rise to our current emotional state
and just how social it really is.
So we talked about early man arriving,
sort of originating in an environment
where it was really important to care for
offspring, right? And
that they be vulnerable,
that we build this important attachment
system of dependency between a caretaker
and their human offspring.
So that it's important
that we have emotions like
compassion and nurturant love.
We also talked about the importance
of relatively monogamous bonds, right?
That we have this strong underlying
tone of commitment to a single partner,
and that this is really important to
build emotions of love and commitment and
the importance of jealousy and keeping
us together with these partners.
Okay.
And then we talked about the
emergence of caring and compassion,
which is due to the fact that
hominids lived very long lives.
And so we're in a society where there's
many older individuals who require
caring, right? And so the existence
of both vulnerable offspring,
young babies as well as older people
really suggest that caring and compassion,
these socially rich emotions are a core
feature of what we've evolved to be.
There's also the flattening of a
social hierarchy in society, right? Um,
that suggests that in many
ways that early societies,
hunter gatherer societies
were relatively egalitarian.
And because we lived
in this egalitarianism,
it was really important to have emotions
that fostered cooperation and bonding
with others.
Yeah.
And then finally we talked about this
need for a collective action related to
the point beforehand where again,
a central part of the societies included
needs for working together towards a
common goal and being cooperative,
being prosocial,
putting aside one's individual needs and
feelings for the bigger, greater group.
So it seems in many ways that we evolved
to be social creatures and hence our
emotions are just so richly
social at all levels.
So when we think about sort
of this introduction to
how social we are and where
it came from, recent researchers have
tried to sort of better quantify this,
to think about,
well,
if emotions are so social and we
live in this inherently social world,
what exactly is the social
purpose or function of emotions,
sort of what do they do for us? Sort
of what, what can they, you know,
feature and unique ways,
you know,
that that makes us function
as social creatures.
So when we think about social
functions of emotion, um,
this has been broken into four main
levels of analysis proposed by Dacher
Keltner and Jonathan Height. And first
they talk about this individual level.
And again, this is a lot of what we
originally studied thus far in the course.
So we've studied emotions as this kind
of sensory response system where we have
really coordinated expressions
in our face, vocal intonations,
things like laughter. We have autonomic,
physiological, you know, signatures,
heart rate,
skin conductance,
breathing that are associated
with different emotions.
And then we also have specific
neurosignatures of emotions as well.
And that these help us sort of solve,
you know,
different types of relationship based
problems as well as survival and group
behavior.
So that's the first level,
okay.
But yet there's more than just the
individual. There's the dyadic level.
So here when we talk about dyadic,
we're talking about a specific exchange
between two individuals or a Dyad,
right?
And so here it's really important to have
an emotional response system where you
can,
you know,
coordinate with another individual in
terms of having facial expressions that
you can pick up on one another using
the important intonation in the voice,
having,
um,
coordinated physiological responses that
mirror one another as you're engaging.
Um,
and even having brain systems that people
now like Jamil Zaki are studying that
help us actually empathize
with other people.
Empathy being the ability
to understand the,
what another person is feeling
or understand cognitively
what they're thinking.
Right? So this dyadic level
is critically important. Um,
the third level of analysis I'll hold on
just really quickly before we get there.
Um,
and turn to this quote by Paul Ekman
who really hearkened at the value and
critical importance of the
dyadic level of, um, you know,
social functions of emotion.
He said the primary function is to
mobilize the organism to deal quickly with
important interpersonal encounters.
So almost the father of human
emotion as we study it today,
really underscored the importance of
emotion as essentially helping us navigate
social or interpersonal endeavors
or encounters. So emotions, again,
are inherently social.
And here what I want to do as well
before we continue further is to make two
important distinctions here.
So the important terminology that we
need to make is between interpersonal and
intrapersonal.
So interpersonal that we see here on the
left with this has really for referring
to his emotions that occur
within an individual. So again,
this is mapping emotional processes
of one specific individual.
And this is contrast with
interpersonal emotions.
So these are emotions between two people
and hear when you study interpersonal
emotions,
you're looking at how emotions structure
relationships among individuals.
Okay.
So again,
what we're going to be talking about
today is we started with a dyadic level of
analysis and we move on to different
levels is are these interpersonal emotions
and if you're a member,
when we talked about dyadic
methods earlier in the course,
hopefully you remember our early lectures
on how to study emotions and different
methods.
We talked about dyadic interactions
here.
When we talked about dyadic interactions,
we had specific examples of two people
coming into the lab and having people,
it could be between spouses, family
members, caregivers, friends,
and often when we study them,
we have them engage in conversations
and at the end of these emotionally
evocative conversations,
we have people write their
emotion experience sort of
how are you feeling right
now as well as their emotion
perception of their partner.
How is their partner feeling right now?
And we talked about some of the kind
of emotion processes you can get when
studying dyadic interactions are
looking at reactivity, regulation,
understanding of emotions
as well as some of the,
some of the advantages as
well as disadvantages of
studying dyadic interactions.
Some of the advantages is you
have good ecological validity.
You're looking at a
naturalistic social context.
And the disadvantages being that they're
somewhat idiographic and that emotional
responses are really complicated when
you study them in to people that they can
be mutually influenced by
both members of the dyad. So
what I want to turn to now is studies
that have looked at dyadic interactions in
married couples and really identified
core emotional ingredients that sort of
predict who are going to go on to have a
successful longterm dyadic relationship
or marriage as a really cardinal example
and which individuals are going to have
trouble.
So here we're thinking about research by
Levinson and Gottman who uncovered the
power of emotion and relationships.
So they found that or they reported that,
you know,
up to 40 to 60% of marriages
end in divorce, right?
And it's often hard to understand
exactly why, right? So, um,
what they tried to do is
they did longitudinal studies
to try to unlock what are
the emotional mechanisms that predict
who do and do not go on to get divorced.
And they identified,
you can see these four circles here,
but they called the four
horsemen of the apocalypse.
So what they did is they brought a
married couples into the lab spouses,
and they have them interact with each
other in these sort of brief 10 minutes
snippets of conflict arguments or topics.
And what they did is they coded
these conversations offline,
watching the videos very carefully, kind
of second by second and identified, well,
what are the ingredients
that predict divorce?
And here's what they found them to be.
So the first was criticism.
So if couples were very critical of
each other and not praising each other,
that was a bad sign. The second was
content. So we can all think of contempt.
It's this idea of people sort of feeling
that they're morally better than the
other sort of looking
down upon their partner.
So if you saw people sneering
during these conflict conversations,
or even like rolling their eyes, that
was a second horseman of the apocalypse.
The third was defensiveness.
So this is where someone sort of maybe
says something to you that sensitive or
critical and you just fire back, right?
You're very defensive, very sensitive,
instead of being able to kind
of engage in the conversation.
And the fourth and the one that I think
is often perhaps the most interesting is
stonewalling.
So this is literally like you become a
stone wall and you just sorta refuse to
talk about anything your
partner thinks is important.
So they found that individuals
in these very brief 10 minute,
if they show these four ingredients that
they were able to predict divorce 13 to
15 years later at a rate of 92% accuracy.
So if you see these four things
in a conversation, in a couple of,
they would say signs are,
it may be bad news.
So what I like to think about taking away
from this is that there's these micro
behavioral,
um,
emotion laden behaviors and just brief
snippets of dyadic interactions between
the two most intimate kinds of
partners. You can think of, you know,
people in a marriage that can be signs
as to the quality of that relationship
even 10, 13, 15 years later.
Yeah.
So the third level then in
this is the group level.
So here we're thinking about big groups
of people and we're thinking about
social hierarchies.
How do people in high versus
low scs situations, you know,
how do they fare emotionally,
how does socioeconomic status plan to
emotional wellbeing as well as power.
So a lot of these studies have been
done by fascinating people like Dacher
Keltner and others at UC
Berkeley that find for example,
that people in low scs situations are
twice as likely to have depression, right?
That they have compromised
immune system functioning, right?
And they've also looked at power and
that individuals with higher power really
display a whole different repertoire of
emotional related behavior with people
of low power settings.
Okay.
And then finally in one
that's particularly important
when we think of kind of
global level conflict and cooperation
is the between group level.
So here what we're talking about
is in group versus out group.
And this is a kind of collective level,
right?
And a very central and
controversial idea here, you know,
comes from sober and Wilson
related to evolutionary theory.
So they would say if we evolved in groups,
which is clearly true,
and if there were numerous
groups competing with each other,
which also happens that there's tens of
thousands of people in specific groups.
So there may be some emotional traits
that helped some groups do better in
competition against other groups.
So it's this idea of ingroup versus
outgroup and what sort of emotional
behaviors give rise to
competition versus collaboration.
So this is a very controversial topic
and plays a really important role and we
think about global conflict and how can
we leverage insights from understanding
emotion and aspect of science to try to
think about emotion on a broader group
level scale
as well as cooperation.
So this has been an
introduction to social emotions.
And for the next second and
third modules in this series,
we're going to have a couple
of very exciting and very
esteemed guests lectures.
And I want to give you a quick sneak
peek as to who's going to be coming up in
the next two modules on social emotions.
Okay.
So one of our guests lectures is a beloved
colleague of here at Yale University.
Dr. Margaret Clark, who's a renowned
expert on emotions and relationships,
and so she's going to speak with us about
some of the most cutting edge findings
as to how we can think about our
emotions and the way they navigate our
relationships,
especially romantic relationships.
We'll also have day at Dr. David Desteno.
I'm from northeastern university who's
just one of the founders of this field of
social emotions,
who's going to be talking with us
about emotions and social interactions
touching across a broad range of
really central and important themes.
Yeah,
so we've talked about an introduction
to what our social emotions,
we've talked about the social function
of emotions across four different levels
of analysis.
Yeah.
I've given you a little sneak peek into
the two upcoming guests lectures that
are going to conclude our
module on social emotions.
And so now we'll conclude
with our takeaway questions.
Our first question asks,
what were the features of the early he
a that gave rise to social emotions and
humans from an evolutionary perspective?
Second,
what were the four levels of analysis
inherent in a social functional approach
to emotion?
And finally,
can you describe what are called the four
horsemen of the apocalypse research by
Gottman and Levinson.
And what does this tell us about emotion,
romantic relationships,
sort of what are the most important
emotional ingredients that can predict who
will and will not go on to have a
healthy romantic a future together.
And we're going to conclude
with our expert interview today.
Yeah.
This is part of our experts
in emotion interview series.
Yeah.
So for this uh, lectures experts
and emotion interview series,
I'll be speaking with Dr. David Rand on
emotion and cooperation in the social
world.
Doctor Rand earned his phd from Harvard
University and systems biology and his
Ba from Cornell University
in computational biology.
His work focuses on human
cooperative behavior.
His approach combines
empirical observations from
behavioral experiments with
predictions generated by evolutionary
game theoretic math models and computer
simulations by doing this doctor ran ass.
What prosocial and antisocial decisions
people make in particular situations and
social environments.
The cognitive mechanisms that determine
how these decisions are actually made
and the ultimate explanations for why our
decision making processes have come to
function as they do.
He draws on methodologies from psychology
as well as economics and evolutionary
biology and is interested in applications
including law management and public
policy. Doctor Ran, has published
in high impact journals,
including nature and science,
was named wired magazine Smart List,
uh, in 2012 as one of 50 young
people who will change the world.
And his work has widely appeared
in the media, including the BBC.
NPR is morning edition marketplace and
all things considered scientific American,
Huffington posts, a New York
Times, La Times, the Atlantic,
The Washington Post,
and Msnbc among many others.
So I now turn to our experts and
emotion interview with Dr. David Rand on
emotion and cooperation
and the social world.
Okay.